hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that today we'll attempt the
unthinkable
celebrate the academy awards with a host
sounds nuts right well that's all we get
day in and day out around this place
something a little more rare is finding
a movie that won the ultimate prize that
oscar has to offer
best picture of the year and as tough
event accomplishment as that may be
it's nothing compared to the formidable
task that now confronts me
mark ellis host of the 2024 oscars
what is the best decade in the history
of the best picture category
which 10-year set features the most
sterling representation
of all that cinema has to offer sweeping
romances epic musical numbers
and human on fish relations that's the
challenge for today's versus
the 1930s versus the 1940s versus the
1950s
versus the do i have to say all the
decades the 60s the 70s okay look
you get the point and now i'll field
some brief questions from the press
corps
excellent question well because the
official oscar ceremony didn't debut
until around 1927
when it crowned wings the best talkie of
the year so it would not be a fair fight
even if i include the great 1990 sitcom
wings
no dice are you afraidy cat
and i have time for one more question
before we begin yes sir from my producer
alex over there
oh why are we even bothering doing this
exercise because the 1940s will of
course win
because citizen kane came out in 1941.
let me stop you right there
we're only considering the best picture
winners from each year
slash decade and old rosebud got the
silver medal at the ensuing oscars
so stay in the dugout orson now pinch
hitting
how green was my valley this press
conference is over
okay fine one more question how do we
determine a winner i thought you'd never
ask
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score
round three team captains round four
end of the bench and then we'll do a
wild card round that could come down to
the english patient
crash green book let's just make a
gentleman's agreement that will honor
each and every one of these flicks
regardless of whether
they deserve to win at the time
gentlemen's agreement
which actually won best picture in 1947
and
i have no idea what it's about but it's
from the 1940s so it probably hasn't
aged all that well
might involve lucky strike cigarettes
take a seat star wars
sit this one out iron man it's best
decade of best picture time
they're the best around nothing's gonna
ever keep them down so well
except me the host let's get it on
frankly my dear i don't give a damn
round one box office because we have
let's see one two uh carry the one nine
decades to sort through
not every decade will get equal air time
in every category
only the contenders and when it comes to
boffo box office we need the decades
that put butts in seats
popcorn and mouse and milk duds on
floors so we start with
the 1950s really hi
hi i should probably point out that our
expert rotten tomatoes researcher mark
hoffmeyer adjusted all the box office
receipts for
inflation did you think i was going to
do that and only four
decades carry averages of above 300
million dollars domestically
per flick only nine films won best
picture in the 1950s
and they combined for an average haul of
359 million dollars
that number is all the more impressive
when you consider that beloved films
like
all about eve and on the waterfront
didn't even crack a 100 million dollar
performance
balancing those under performances out
is the mighty ben
herr who has the decade's high mark at
919 million dollars
it was all about those sprawling epics
that had to be seen to be believed
the greatest show on earth around the
world in 80 days and the bridge on the
river kwai
all went above the 300 million dollar
mark that's a lot of nickels kids
fasten your seatbelts it's going to be a
bumpy night
the 1950s ranks fourth on the list of
the highest box office decades for best
picture winners
the champ is the very next decade the
1960s you had your sprawling epics still
ruling the day
as evidenced by lawrence of arabia's
giant gross
in 1962 but this decade was dominated at
the top
by soaring musicals including the
all-time heavyweight
the sound of music which broke the
mythical billion dollar mark one
adjuster for inflation
at 1.33 billion dollars
other notables were my fair lady and
west side story which helped the 1960s
carry a tune of 457 million bucks
as a per film average that bests its
younger cousin the 1970s
only by 31 million dollars only 31 mil
the decade that ushered in new pioneers
into the world of film boasts the
godfather one
and two combining for over a billion
bucks as well as 1975's
one flew over the cuckoo's nest and
rocky doing very well the very next year
but which of the 1970s flicks had the
most box office receipts
yo adrian it's uh none of those it's the
sting
at 835 million dollars that
is one big con kramer vs kramer closed
out the decade on a high note
of 403 million dollars and then surely
the 1980s would lead to more
i'm being told no no the 80s the 2000s
and the 2010s
are all leading only the 1930s which we
don't have reliable data for
people maybe didn't rush out in droves
to see best picture material like they
used to
which makes the 1990s something of an
anomaly
that decade was certainly a box of
chocolates as crowd pleasers like
forrest gump at 710 million
and titanic sailing at 1.2 billion help
make up for the lesser seen movies like
the english patient
at 162 million and braveheart at 163
million
braveheart really it only beat that
desert snoozefest by a million bucks
yes what else defeated william wallace
that decade
uh hannibal lecter oscar schindler and
even loving bill shakespeare were all
characters in films that grossed more at
the box office
the 1990s overall average per best
picture champion
is 380 million dollars now that's good
for third place all time
and one wonders what might have been if
something like saving private ryan
had edged out shakespeare in love well
it still wouldn't get the decade to even
second place
okay okay but what if goodfellas had
defeated dances with wolves in 1990
that it actually would have hurt the
overall average you see
civil war kevin costner and his 409
million dollar total
won over theater goers that year even
given all this data which again
i researched none of myself i could make
a strong argument for the 1990s winning
this round
more movies were being released which
means more competition for those best
pictures at the box office
but the 1960s are so important because
they set the template
for what audiences want to see at the
films forevermore
musicals to stir the song in our heart
huge productions to wow us like lawrence
of arabia
and if you think the 1970s was the most
influential decade from a filmmaking
standpoint
i would point to edgy flicks like 1969's
midnight cowboy
for that inspiration
i'm going with the 1960s as my box
office champion
the hills are alive with the sound of a
point for the hippie movement
make love not war but if you do make war
you should then make a film about it
because those
tend to do well at the oscars
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
speaking of battles when you involve a
party bust chock full of oscar winners
and take them to a tomato meter round
you can expect more scoring than all
three porky's movies combined
are any of those movies no are we sure
yeah
probably not okay well what we do have
in store are a bunch of decades that lit
up the tomato meter but before we get to
the lofty standards of those critics
how'd our best picture champions fare
with the audience
every year moviegoers flocked to the
cinema to catch up on the award show
contending movies this audience score is
filled with the hopes and dreams of
millions of ordinary people expecting to
see a quality content
or at least figure out who to vote for
in their oscar pool and thanks to all
you fine folks we now welcome to the
inner
circle the 1980s that's right the same
decade that saw the rise of tom hanks
the fall of the berlin wall and steve
trevor stealing some poor washington dc
resident's body
also gave us all-time beloved best
picture winners like chariots of fire
and driving miss daisy really that's the
best we can okay look i'll be honest
this was the decade that must have seen
kleenex stock
soar because oscar winners like terms of
endearment and ordinary people
ruled the ceremony but at least we got
the incredible music of wolf gang mozart
his middle name was amadeus and that
movie boasts the highest audience score
of the decade at 95 percent platoon
rain man and gandhi also landed at 90 or
above
helping the 1980s to an impressive 87.3
audience score average which is i also
believe the percentage of the popular
vote reagan won over walter mondale
hey i got political make me sad right
despite its audience score the 1980s
don't have much of a shot in this round
because it's seemingly really good
tomato meter average
of 83.7 percent it only gets into eighth
place
amongst the decades in contention so we
leave the 1980s and pull it back to the
future
too because we're skyrocketing to the
2010s
its audience score is good only for a
middling pedestrian 86.1 percent average
per film
however its tomato meter average ranks
second only to the 1970s
at 93 percent that's on the strength of
i mean moonlight and parasite both of
which earned
98 percent and spotlight with a 97
as a matter of fact the only movie
weighing down this decade is green book
as it's the one film in this set that
failed to hit at least 90
on the tomato meter at 77 the only other
decade that could challenge the 1970s
and the 2010s
would be the 1940s casablanca has a 95
audience score and a 99 tomato meter
rating
is looking at you kid the only movie
besting that classic is the 1940
talking picture rebecca which sits at a
toy story approved
a hundred percent on the tomato meter
this is all the more heartbreaking
because you know what else is it a
hundred percent on the tomato meter
citizen kane it's the mike tyson of
movies
but how green was my valley is james
buster douglas the actual best picture
winner of 1941 the
valley movie sits at 89 on the tomato
meter
so look you may have had a nice green
valley but citizen kane is a mountain
that casts a very
large shadow so for this round the tea
leaves are starting to lean towards the
1970s
after all critically acclaimed
masterpieces like the godfather one and
two
the french connection and patton all won
that decade
so why am i considering the 2010s to win
well unlike the 1970s or 60s or 80s or
any full decade before it
the 2010s winners had to emerge from a
field of
10 best picture contenders not five it
also set numerous milestones
for diversity in filmmaking parasite was
the first film with an
asian director to win best picture when
bong joon ho took home gold
12 years a slave was the first film
directed by a black man steve mcqueen
to win best picture and birdman was the
first film directed by a hispanic latino
man to win
thanks to the incomparable alejandro
gonzalez inauritu
and the icing on the cake would be the
artist where audiences were treated
to a throwback celebration of the
talkies before they could
you know talk luckily i can speak and i
did it so convincingly that i gat myself
into taking the 2010s
as my round two winner the 1960s and the
2010s are now
on the board
cut perfect
round three team captains full
disclosure i almost called this round
the best of the best
but then i was informed that none of the
best of the best films starring tv's
eric roberts were ever even nominated
for an oscar and i threatened to walk
off set
i vented my trailer for three hours then
returned with the idea of
team captains you see in sports a team
will select a captain
or two or three to be the leader of the
squad the first ones charging into
battle
or at least the coin toss here i'll fact
in a robust buffet of elements and
considering which movies should be the
representatives of their respective
decades
and with all apologies to the 1980s once
again
best of the best will not be making an
appearance okay
a point is on the line who wants to show
their best of the
cream of the crop first like anyone born
in that decade the 1930s wake up first
and that's of course on the strength of
gone with the wind and its eight oscar
wins in 1939.
mutiny on the bounty is also a heralded
benchmark of cinema from that era and
i'll also toss in
all quiet on the western front as a
captain if only because it helped a
nation of high school freshmen
not have to read the book the 1960s
answered the call and maybe end the
1930s hopes with the gigantic
1-2 musical punch of west side story
which won 10
oscars off of 11 nominations and the
sound of music
i'm also going to put in the heat of the
night as a team captain to give that
movie
some valuable minutes speaking of value
how great was the dawn of the new
millennium
the 2000s were fun we survived y2k
stopped using the phrase
surfing the net and boldly stepped into
the future
by going back to ancient times with
gladiator we were also treated to a
throwback musical in chicago
but the standout in this decade is
return of the king that
little hobbit movie oh it won best
picture of course
and 10 other oscars making for a total
of 11 and vaulting it into the greatest
movie trivia question
ever name the two other films that won
11 oscars
it's been her in 1959 and titanic in the
1990s
in fact that boat movie and schindler's
list and unforgiven
those would make good team captains good
the 90s are set
but the decade that many consider the
true foundation of modern cinema
features a slate of movies that may have
yet to be matched the 1970s
you could make the argument that the
deer hunter annie hall
and patton would make solid cases for
captaincy in most
10-year sets however they don't even
crack the top five of the 1970s
you got the godfathers rocky cuckoo's
nest
maybe the sting they'd all be great
representatives of the decade in my
opinion
and now i've upset both of the kramers
because i left them off
the list look it was nothing short of a
cinematic revolution taking place back
in the 70s kids
william friedkin and francis ford
coppola meryl streep and jack nicholson
robert redford and paul newman pacino
and de niro
in the same movie the 1970s had all the
right stuff
wait that was an 80s movie to win any of
the rounds we've had thus far
but even rocky balboa himself had to
endure the sting of defeat before he
reaped the glory of victory
the 1970s are running through this round
like crap through a goose
thanks for the reference general patton
you can't deny the decade that would
forevermore change our relationship with
motion pictures
and there's no way i would deny the
mafia yet another win during this
episode
the 1970s take round three and it's a
tie at the top between them
the 1960s and the 2010s
what have i ever done to make you treat
me so disrespectfully
round four end of the bench each and
every year hollywood turns out great
cinema that will stand the test of time
for decades to come
but along with that comes um the other
movies
i did not oh hi mark
even our all-time favorite franchises
have been burdened with a
weakest link indiana jones has kingdom
of the crystal skull
jaws has any movie that's not the
original and star wars has any film not
named return of the jedi
but surely the oscars would never bestow
the honor of best picture on
any work of art that's lesser than right
not so fast today's matchup is all about
the decade as a whole
so not just the best of the best but
also who's sitting at the end of the
bench
the worst movie of each decade that
still won best picture
which cinematic attempt is the best of
the worst
the loudest of the lame and no i will
not use this round to further make fun
of how green was my valley
i'm sure it was plenty um
ripe but i can make fun of crash somehow
it's only tied for the lowest tomato
meter score of any best picture flick in
the 2000s
sharing a 74 with a beautiful mind
both improved on the audience square
metric although crash couldn't break 90
percent
and it got shellacked by the star power
of russell crowe jennifer connolly
and an imaginary friend a beautiful mind
would gross 276 million dollars
domestically
crash just 79 million the next decade
the 2010s would also see a lower than
expected tomato meter score win best
picture
green book at 77 percent but i'll at
least give that movie credit for
occasionally succeeding it being a sort
of feel-good
story crash is just so much star power
so little everything else how about a
decade where the worst best picture
winner is still a fun rewatchable movie
here comes robert zemeckis no i'm not
referring to back to the future
what did win in 1985 out of africa
okay yeah no huey lewis in that
soundtrack okay whoa this is heavy
there's that word again heavy but i'm of
course talking about the 1990s when
robert zemeckis directed forrest gump
running all the way to center stage at
the then
kodak theater to take home top honors to
greenbeau alabama
the movie is only 71 percent on the
tomato meter but rebounds with a solid
titanium
95 audience score
plus the only movie that gump takes a
second place to in terms of cable
replays
is probably the shawshank redemption hey
those pictures came out around the same
week
predictably the 1970s proved to be far
as stiffest competition in this round
as we try to figure out which decade has
the best player hidden deep on the
sidelines
back then it would be the only movie of
that decade to win best picture
but fall short of hitting 90 on the
tomato meter as 1979's
kramer vs kramer nabbed 88 percent
other films further in the past that had
a curiously low tomato meter
were the sound of music at 83 percent
and ben hurried 86
i know what you're asking don't worry
thankfully mrs miniver
still safe 94 so this is all about
kramer vs
gump clearly two films intended to
inspire different emotions within us
but they both crushed it at the domestic
box office kramer vs kramer did 403
million dollars worth of business
that's amazing those are transformers
numbers star power has never gone out of
style and in 1994
tom hanks was at his absolute apex the
rom-com dude and buddy dramatic
powerhouse was coming off of his first
oscar win for 1993's philadelphia
and pulled off the rare repeat with
forrest the very next year
that film would go on to gross over 700
million dollars domestically
and sell a boatload of double cds we
only forget to talk about that
soundtrack now because it was released
between the bodyguard and titanic
but my heart will always still go on
loving you gump
i don't even like shrimp bubba gump
shrimp
it's a household name the 1990s are
going to take this round and get on the
board
and for anyone crying hey hey what about
the english patient
we may not care about it now but it's a
95
on the tomato meter so my hands are tied
and come on did you really watch this
show to
hear my ray finds desert hot takes we're
moving on
for one chance just one chance to come
back here
and tell our enemies that they may take
our lives
[Music]
and now it's time for the wild card
round lawrence gump
vs birdman no this round is not a
literal battle between a flying man
and a guy named larry gump but that
title is indicative of the four decades
that got us here
the 1960s 70s 90s and 2010s
each decade's got a point so far today
and no those decades are not going to
have to rely
just on those titles in this round we're
gonna wax philosophic about each 10-year
period
consider how it further the art of
cinema and ultimately make a decision
for
our winner so who wants to go first
i remember some of the oscar ceremonies
in the 2010s so let's start there
the biggest thing going for this decade
is the aforementioned diversity in front
of
and behind the camera but also the
stories that were being told
12 years of slave and moonlight
illuminated different shades of people
battling oppression
in a quite literal sense the shape of
water took an allegorical approach to
the biases of its time
there were the twists and turns of
parasite the truth-seeking expose of
spotlight and the historical uplift of
the king's speech
wait have i not mentioned that movie
today oh it's so good
i have a voice yes you do bertie ah
makes me cry every time
can i have a voice
yes you do argo gave us fast-paced
tension
the artist provided a throwback
pre-talking masterpiece
and birdman was very different so wacky
but holy hell what an achievement
appearing to be all one massive two-hour
shot
birdman is a testament to the increasing
amount of oddball originality that can
shine through come awards season
the 2010s were a decade of possibility
thanks to a more level playing field
we're not where we need to be yet
but at least there's hope the 1990s
crushed at the box office and i mean
godzilla style
and no not the 1998 fake one with the
velociraptors of madison square garden
in fact the weakest box office draw of
that decade the english patients 162
million dollars
is a higher total than anything that won
best picture in the 2010s
while that and braveheart bring up the
rear in terms of moolah movies like
american beauty
unforgiven silence of the lambs and
schindler's list all performed over 200
million dollars
with obviously titanic decimating
anything in its path
at 1.2 billion bucks she's no wonder
that band kept playing they were making
bank historical epics western revivals
and twisted love stories are a hallmark
of the 1990s best picture winners and
this time period
just may remain the zenith when high art
met commerce
and jogged their way across american
multiplexes and although the 1960s are
the deserved box office champion
that decade will be celebrated more for
the event films it had to be
seen to be believed before dinosaurs and
lightsabers and parachuting cars piloted
by vin diesel were the tentpole films
the 1960s filled our hearts with song
west side story the sound of music and
my fair lady left indelible marks with
soaring high notes
but they weren't the only reason to go
to the movies in the 1960s 1959's ben
hur was indeed a harbinger of wide scale
epics to follow
and lawrence of arabia fulfilled that
promise so well
it still is one of the most sought after
tickets when it's brought back on the
big screen
seriously i live in la i showed up to
arclight to see it at the dome a couple
years ago
no tickets left not even for famous
people like me
and in the same way that judah ben hur
and his chariot racing brethren proved
what puts butts in seats for the next
decade
1969's midnight cowboy helped pave the
way for a new crop of filmmakers to
eschew musicals
in favor of more gritty realism in their
stories cue the godfather music
look i don't condone a horse head to be
a reliable indicator that a movie is
going to be great
but it sure worked for francis ford
coppola the only debate about the
greatness of the godfather films
is which one you prefer one or two and
chances are
you'll still end up watching them both
and then you'll think about watching the
third
and then you're just gonna put the
sopranos on instead the french
connection and the sting
joined the corleones as hard-hitting
realistic feeling crime-based epics
meanwhile the 1970s also gave us
shattering dramas with no
shortage of societal commentary with one
flew over the cuckoo's nest
the deer hunter and that kramer matchup
the horrors of war in patton were
balanced out by the humor and intellect
of modern day romance
with annie hall and lest we forget the
1970s
gave us the all-time underdog to cheer
for
paulie remember adrian's down-and-out
brother
hey look rocky was at least making a
living paulie
not so much so how does one render a
decision as to which decade is the
all-time
goat in terms of best picture box office
helps
influence is a must and good movies tend
to win me over
each decade features at least a little
bit of this magic elixir
but the 1970s taught us how to perfect
the craft of filmmaking
rocky set a new standard for sports
movies in the same way that annie hall
revolutionized the romantic comedy
the godfather didn't invent the mob
picture it just perfected it
and then the godfather two ran it back
movies became must-see events in the
1960s
they showed us reflections of ourselves
and our past in the 1990s
and they became more inclusive to
everyone in the 2010s
but the 1970s took motion pictures and
put them on the same bar with high art
like beloved novels
classical music and all those cool
pictures on the roof of the sistine
chapel
the movies made from the 1970s made tons
of money and earned unrivaled critical
acclaim
but they also paved the way for all that
was to come
including some talking video jock he's
still fawning over how great that
opening monologue from george c
scott is in patton it was like he was
given a pep talk to the rest of the
decade for the best picture winners
to go out there and win this episode of
versus
the 1970s take the wild card round and
thus
the match the very thought of losing
is hateful but that's just one guy's
opinion and maybe i've seen rocky one
too many times
now truth be told i've actually seen
rocky iv way too many times
but here on this earth on this day there
was no easy way out
and no shortcut home we took you on a
journey through time and space to
witness the evolution
of commercial machines for popping corn
and the blathering big screen you stare
at while you eat it
you can take my opinion with you but
we'd also love to hear from all of our
fellow film lovers out there
hit us up on social media and let me
know which decade you think has the very
best batch of best picture winners
do you agree it's the 1970s or are you
wrong
i'm sorry sorry that was rude what is
your take
that's the real question and only you
can answer it until next time i'm mark
ellis
and this could be the beginning of a
beautiful friendship
unless you've already watched more
episodes of versus in which case
i'm just gonna go home to the apartment
hey
it's a one bedroom spacious one bedroom
it's in the valley
the green valley how green was it i
don't know